once a full podcast was so full podcast
welcome to the were so full part can
everybody who's listening to us on
Monday morning the next week or
listening to a live right now our
Wednesday at 12:15 here on Wednesday
promotion they put a poll up mundane
ways they do a second push but you're
Tory's right here boo Lisa right here we
got matching suits our guest is here
zeyneb Johnson Last Comic Standing
Helen we also had the holy that was here
may be left with those puppets it's
cutting no bro be a comedian here the
white comedian he'll be super super down
magic oh wow I don't know that we're
talking about before really a little kid
like is that with a cop I was living in
Philly Addison
I'll make this straw just appease a
table that happens a lot how you you
hang out with somebody a whole week you
feel a little bit newer says four days
yeah tell me when I leave the club
everybody's day was so full for a
weekend full of to leave the room Barrow
everybody [ __ ] anymore bro I did um
Club miss Annie and so no no El Paso the
comic strip comic strip El Paso yes and
they just kept talking do you know
Felipe do you know Felipe do you know
Felipe we took Phillippe way to this
vegan restaurant we did this with Felipe
I'm like okay sucks at that place the
tile like fell on them like a piece of
I was there I think in the summer and
they have that they have that um yeah
but they had like they brought in like a
air conditioning like a big thing but it
wasn't yeah the owner and his staff they
were great you know they were nice to me
but it it was hard to 100 views outside
and they were at there by the ice
machine cuz I mean she gets hot too it
was ice machine is in the green room you
have you have to actually walk through
like the stock cabinet - yeah yeah but
if you're not go hard like you know if
you like beat drinkin beer water grab a
beer huh yeah yeah from the ice machine
comes in the green in the green room
yeah which is smaller than this table I
started I started out with that Club
where they had a need to be at some
other place like across history flagged
in the west side like they their icon
but yeah yeah
[Laughter]
they don't have the white strap I really
are saying that all those pleats people
are making fun of these shoes I think
they're comfortable that what we
stretched it out bro so you can wear it
but Bill Cosby and they're in a baseball
team you know what yeah I was gonna get
you a Richard Pryor shirt from the
website but then I may do that other
show cuz I thought it would be funnier
well the one big dog we have we have a
mutual friend here they about big dog
was just named after the show find out
what time he got drunk at his house and
you show him everything like April is
about tonight shows that my personal
attention night show says that's 40
minutes of videos and now we found his
um his like a photo up here when you
were little faith he like I shaved away
because now I guess he was contacts now
and whatever so this footprint to the
other shirts a lot of comedians
challenge yourself bro but if we were to
wear that [ __ ] it'll probably break his
heart but uh we're thinking of doing a
live podcast one day I thought some
comedy club and invite our guests and
have our fate our favorite kids on the
show invite the listeners the listeners
and would you stand up you know probably
cut off the tape for the stand-up you
know it will be the comedian to do stand
away with the last time and then when we
have here be our big gasp dog on the
podcast you think he'll do it
I would even shows up where everybody
will have everybody
don't know do it well everybody having a
good time in the podcast talking about
how you know I love him if he's honest
you know I love this dude and then we're
all everybody just go now a bird takes
off the shirt it would worry about
t-shirt I think I think it'll be good
with the fact that a lot of people don't
know them like we do them and asking the
questions in the right way of people
like like older comics like who are like
whatever people say oh I received a man
[ __ ] right but they're out there working
you know they're out there headlining
part 3 gets all older fools in the
trenches but like apologia we're doing
like a good podcast later we thought
this podcast people follow him
oh yeah could we get $78 listeners bro
hell yeah
78,000 now bro how many fools good wait
I was gonna ask you you ever heard that
saying they say if you give a person
shoes as a gift they're gonna walk all
over you have you ever heard that you
just coined that phrase no no no that's
like that's here maybe maybe it's a
black thing maybe it's like a southern
black thing but that part you've never
heard that comment letter I don't know
now you tell me hey where you from I'm
from New York oh yeah yeah yeah a
gentleman named John said one more time
man were you from that I'm from New York
I was born in Brooklyn I grew up in
Harlem Brooklyn let Brooklyn our
Brooklyn Brooklyn in the 80s
whoa Brooklyn in the mid-eighties oh
yeah yeah well I could shake about your
mother those times too though yeah I
mean when I moved to Harlem they were
still like crack vials and stuff in the
street and then as I grew up in Harlem I
watched the change happen like I watched
it go from like a lot of abandoned
buildings to like all the Lots being
filled up the buildings being built up
to you know people who look different
from us moving into the neighborhood
like I watched it all happen there
watching like in movies like when they
show like that's a Washington in that
movie Malcolm X militia of the Warriors
and they'll show Brooklyn was it really
that bad were like it was just one big
giant building with nobody there and
then another one with nobody there then
people in like because I saw a lot of
New York I support that Brule it
literally somebody just a bomb yeah yeah
but I mean Malcolm X in that's what in
the sixties right yeah that's been the
60s so I didn't see that but but I do
like the slumlords we are ting to like
abandon their buildings and but I assure
Inspiron I was a kid I remember I was
really like a young kid the mayor mayor
Dinkins
he allowed people in New York to pop to
buy all of those abandoned buildings for
$1 and a lot of people my dad even
bought one but then the kicker was the
taxes on the end you had to bring it up
to living code in a year and most people
didn't have the money exactly to do that
so it's like a bunch of people bought it
for a dollar and then just lost it
that's a good scare huh I think it was a
scam I think I think I think I think
that's like built for like developers
that are like you have experience yeah
and then before you even get a building
code it's like just the money to like
lay brick by brick it's just it's
expensive she doesn't hit the building
we didn't get to building we didn't get
the building but my dad I moved into it
when I moved to Harlem we moved into a
tenement building and my dad turned the
tenement building into a co-op building
we bought our apartment and then my
parents sold it for much more than what
they'd pay for it so he figured it out
eventually
Mitchell at this army base right there
and I'm Brooklyn Bay Bridge yeah Bay
Bridge would be rich pay range the guy
that was running everything like
together in charge of us turns out to
eat got his weed no anyways that dude
went to his rooftop and we saw the
bridge
but the Bay Bridge right there but he
said that the older apartment like his
mom bought it back in a daze yeah he was
telling me how much the apartment worth
the apartment was shitty thought well
you know I'm used to live in our lathe I
was a widow you get to walk out yeah but
that's prime real estate now we have two
bedrooms a big-ass kitchen and I have
one half bathroom but I mean you think
about it
even owning something like that all you
have to do is update it and an update is
only a shell remodeling it's not really
going deep in it you know and you could
you could flip that apartment for like
tripled the front the apartments that
were $900 20 years ago in New York can
go for $10,000 a month and some people
pay it that's where like normal people
don't have a chance
yeah it's like everybody's being priced
out I think that for me it's like I
personally lovely seeing like growth in
a neighborhood but it sucks because the
people who built that very neighborhood
you price them out you know and that
happens every way that's not just in New
York that's happening in LA happening in
Detroit is happening in a lot of cities
across the country people Fresno getting
married to the game price for $1,200 is
true gorgeous don't worry though you
watch the news
yeah they're talking about how much the
rest going up but they show this card
will be billed right they were growing
to be shitty they're 250 a month no
Downtown Fresno bro bye bye the one by a
bicycle one could buy the sub casino
there and with 1200 for one beds with a
lot of money yeah it's like I don't know
when I I'm not that familiar what
informs on like poverty levels and
things like that but there are a lot of
people in the United States that are
literally living off of $10,000 a year
comedians comedians have a couch to stay
on this you know people living over
$10,000 trying to raise children you
and pricing they can't afford to spend
more than a certain amount of rent I
tripped out when the teacher strike this
is 20,000 homeless children yeah there
were homeless kids that were we knew
we're homeless
I mean I knew which one these kids in
Isaac's class were homeless and it was
sad because like their parents would
show up and they basically had
everything on their backs everything and
they go to shelter and do homework after
school and it said I was homeless and
for a little while when we were in
Brooklyn and it is I don't know I think
is I think that's their like beauty and
being a kid you know you don't like I
remember hating not having like a place
to live although we my mom has a lot of
kids and so we were in a women's shelter
and the thing about there's no family
shelters there's always women's shelters
and saying I want to hear that we
support Cesar Chavez that means that if
it's like if it's a full family meaning
a mother father and children that means
the father has to go wherever he is
going and then the mother and the
children can stay but I remember my like
my greatest memory from that two things
from the shelter I climbed on a metal
bookshelf and it came down on me and my
mom kept telling me don't climb on that
bookshelf don't climb on that bookshelf
and as soon as nobody was watching me I
climbed on that damn book shelf and the
bookshelf just came down on me and I
don't I guess I didn't get hurt and then
the blankets that we had in the shelter
were those wool blankets there sometimes
they have like as the in between blanket
in hotels yeah so whenever I see
whenever I see those blankets I'm like
keeping blankety-blank you become rug 13
yeah you're the oldest
no no I'm fifth from the family yeah
mm-hmm
13 let that we were a lot 7 yeah with
both parents
for we'll just do a lotto refuge with
Allah right yeah now they it now it's
like everyday Armando are our parents
remember that movie with desert watch so
we got Peter took off mo better blues
where that girls cry to the football he
did not bother they had a job they had a
job with me bro we always have to go
with him like you know pick up nail
something you said I hate that we'll
take off no no no when I was talking
about is well Gloria was telling me
about
Mondo's father he would they would get
paid every 15 days so they would come
home there was two families living in
one big house and the two men were
brothers it would come home they would
get ready they would already cash your
checks they'll give the mom a hundred
bucks and they wouldn't return the leap
Friday night and come back all messed up
barely early as Monday morning or very
late Sunday night and that would happen
every 15 days did the $100 cover all the
bills I don't know if he did or not but
there was getting back to party and then
my homie the mouse his his sister's
husband the dad would take he'll get
paid weekly and he would take off and
they would actually go and find him and
TJ I like laid out or just like all
Koror in LA like there was two or three
spots where they were from where they
would find that ad and no money my
parents never drank we grew up in like a
strict Muslim house so they never drank
smoked my mom smoked cigarettes except
when she was pregnant in breastfeeding
which is all that one time where there
was like a three you know three year gap
between the kids I know she was in
heaven but so I never liked my dad we
always had like activities we always did
like family trips and I don't know we we
were always just a unit I think that's
why now I'm such a loner because now I'm
just like don't attach to me don't get
away from me get away from me only
original participants yeah Wow 13 people
do you put in your act
yeah all the time I thought it's it's
now so say it's not the only thing I
talk about but I talk about often what
you start doing Stan what do you say you
know what made you become a comedian
like I know happen to me I would always
watch late-night
Jeff Jam that should blew your boobie or
without their Channel oh just like I
couldn't believe how funny they were yes
Martin Lawrence later or the little
comic parts on the movie I'm living in a
[ __ ] hovel do the right thing dude it
remember Robin Harris I'll talk to shoot
those little comic part yeah yeah I did
I mean I saw things when I was like
younger like I might have when you know
maybe 10 years or so after they came out
I saw a bra and I thought it was like
the funniest thing I'd ever seen
and then somebody was like you got to
see delirious that's the first part and
I was like okay and I watched it and I
was like that's not as funny as raw to
me but it made the jokes and raw more
funnier because it was like a
continuation but I didn't I started
doing stand-up august 2 2010 and I I
don't know the day I did it was the day
that I thought about it I never thought
about it before then ever I wish I had a
better story I wish I wish that it was
something that was in my heart for like
years but the day that it hit me and hit
me strong you know so yeah
me I mean I didn't get to hang out you
know like at a comedy club for a long
time
I just went looked in the alley weekly
and I saw hoping Mike and I went over
there and I signed up and I did it I
didn't look I bombed I did open my I did
my first open mic at a hookah lounge and
it was right near my hello hookah lounge
like a Middle Eastern hookah lounge in
North Hollywood and I was like it's
gonna go bad so it's like that's all I
thought Google and it was like
first-come first-served five minutes you
know and I just went I was like okay
this is close to my house so when it
goes bad I could just go upstairs and
nobody will know that this happened and
then I got I did it and it didn't go
that bad and one of the first things I
said was that I was one of 13 and that
made everybody in the place go wait what
she's I saw that guy and then I was like
and then when they looked at me I was
like from the same mother and father and
then they were like and I just realized
like oh that's the thing for people like
I didn't you know how like your regular
life you don't realize how people are
gonna be affected by it and so that's
where I started I know that right right
nothing like the next generation you
know like you have to kill your five and
there are four different people but like
my family's ever like I have to be care
they're from different ladies you know
like was I like going up through school
okay like probably over the house a lot
my dad a lot of people I went to high
school with me there are two weeks yeah
but a lot of my friends were like I want
to start a family I'm gonna be the job
how are you what a college girl yeah
with the college I graduated from
college and I do want children
City College in New York I went to grad
school did you nice nice did you study
loan and okay I got my MBA there okay
got you
what I said I was a good generation I
work for you now so charity gig last
weekend during the rape wait what sorry
last weekend through the horrible rain
because of driving anywhere for a game
oh wait wait I did have to drive
somewhere
oh I drove to Santa Barbara to do it
like that yeah you did the one on
watching the 101 yeah
yeah we had a show and oh yeah
Visalia Visalia take it away whose
choice will show back thank you very
much both shows sold out this that
weekend we knew was sold out we know but
you know what that's a good things like
people can't be out they need but they
don't want to be in a house like they'd
seen enough of each other been raining
for like two weeks like comedy club is
great bad way I'm from the when I could
do comedy in New York the winter is the
best it's like bad weather everybody is
packed into the comedy clubs so how's
your last comic standing like did you
audition they hook you up but you
started lying no I didn't have an agent
when I did last Comic Standing I
auditioned why did I go dish you part of
the like the whole cattle call group of
people like the large group no are you
actually you had an appointment had an
appointment so I did this show I did
this show a little while before that I
had showcased for I did a show with
Kevin Hart and I was showcasing for Dave
Becky at the time and the guy who hosted
the show was a writer on one of Wanda
shows that she was taping in like
Chicago or something like that and when
I finished my set he was like I'm gonna
you should be on the show that I'm doing
what Wanda you should be on the show and
I was like okay well thank you and then
time passed and I never heard anything
and he had emailed me maybe a couple of
months after that like hey I just wanted
to send you to email just so you know
that I did put in a good word we just
already had the comics book you know
yet whatever and so they
and I had auditioned I did a cattle sort
of call audition for the stands up for
diversity NEC and San Diego San Diego
yeah yeah and I did the semi-final I did
the semi-finals
and I felt like I killed there here's
why I feel like I killed beyond just me
killed but beyond me having a strong
seven minutes I went on after drew you
guys know drew who has to set the stuff
I'm Sutter super Posey
no no so he has Russian or something
like that like a little white guy guy
you know and little like literally in
height little but I think he got his big
break now on America's Got Talent cuz
like me you know
anywho he's a guy with a stuff with a
something tragic happened to him in his
life and it caused a stutter right and
so not only is his material funny but he
got a stutter so it brought the house
down and then I go up right after him
the Holston dust it off a bit nothing
just brought me right up and I still
crushed chop your legs up and I still
with no disabilities no I still destroy
and I was like I'm sure I'm going to the
front like I'm sure I'm doing this
finals in LA like showcasing right and I
didn't get it in our you know how many
you don't get I don't know you guys tell
me if you feel like well you don't get
something you gotta go watch who got it
right I was like let me see who they
thought was better than me so I'm
sitting there and it was not a of can't
believe I'm saying this out loud it was
a pretty weak showcase that year and I
think that the person running it just
alright it wasn't like like what she was
looking the way she made her decisions
wasn't in the best interest of like oh
I'm trying to showcase talent they can't
you got him saying it wasn't in the best
case
versity in my opinion exactly in my
opinion so I'll leave the show I'm
waiting at the front of the improv for
my friend's car to come around because
he valeted I would never valet out I'll
look 27 minutes for parking so we're
waiting for his valet and then I hear
somebody say behind me Zainab did you go
on and I turned around was Wanda Sykes
and I was like oh no I didn't go on she
was like okay I'm good because I would
have been upset if I missed you and I
was like okay and then my friend looks
at me he's like I didn't know you knew
one two Sykes I was like I don't want to
say but just go with it
and then after that I had got a like a
call like an invitation to audition for
Last Comic Standing appointment in I
auditioned could you follow her mess oh
I I don't remember who I follow the
judges the judges were Russell Peters
Keenen Ivory Wayans and Roseanne Barr
but what I do remember although it
didn't air this way was we had to get
there probably like three o'clock in the
afternoon and I was the 24th person it
went up in Jimmy Schubert was the 25th
person that went up and we got on stage
slightly before midnight the crowd the
audience have been there from like 85 30
and that so they had been here for like
five hours yeah and we still went out
there and crushed it yeah you know but
it like you don't see that obviously
it's showing out of sequence but I was
24th and he was 25th how about this [ __ ]
like nobody there yeah there was nobody
there there was just a bunch of
executives with big piles it was in a
daytime at Universal why Jon Lovitz Club
and it was really dark because it's huge
is such a huge flow yeah and it is maybe
like 15 people in there but they're all
like executives you know eating lunch
starbursts yeah but but who you rely on
there's still talent coordinators
there's people there's PA they're
walking you to there's people working
and if you get if you made the security
guy laugh who stands in post and you
know you
do you know what I'm saying then you
know you did well regardless of what
they chose if you made the people that
are there having nothing to do with
everything and then they act you a bunch
of questions cuz it's a reality show
they want a story you know so if you got
a good set and then you say I was kids
you know or whatever you could say like
I die you know I swam here from Jamaica
are you having a story as what helped
you I spoke to everybody who got kicked
off I talked to Alonzo Bodden I talked
to Dante Italian Dante
I spoke to fluffy he told me you know
just be honest everything you know and
to other people I was just honest they
asked me if you or not made it through
what you were done I said why you will
saw me unlocked by a bike right here no
I showed up at a beach cruiser out of
your bike on side yeah and if you'll be
unlocking it and if we won't be riding
my bike holding the red ticket yeah make
you feel like crying on TV what did you
people love the story how big was that
big it was terrible it was terrible and
then they brought us in you know
standards and practice they got to give
you all because it's a reality show so
you can't say it you got to keep the
results of it secret it doesn't matter
what happened if you get past or you get
moved on to the next round you got to
just keep it inside you can't say what
we do on Facebook like just you know you
can't do it and then the comedian did it
I can't say who did what you see them
who are not my favorite right Rodman
ride me
yeah yeah mm-hmm I think the hardest
part when you were in it the hardest
part was having to submit your jokes
you're set ahead of time and stick to
that exact set because you don't stick
to your sets when you write down a set
you stray from it you know like often
you'll write a set and you won't do any
of those jokes when you go up there it
just gets your juices flowing
yeah I had to change a couple of things
with junior he could say I did have to
change some jokes but again I have been
doing it for like three and a half years
I had very few jokes that I'm gonna
choose they say something then it was
like okay well I ain't got nothing else
for you before you go I was only a
semi-finalists
know I got eliminated right before they
announced the top ten but I think that
my jokes sit out and I had a shaved head
and I'm 6 feet tall so when I even when
I um me and Jimmy we went on the road
together after that people will come up
to me be like you one last comic
standing right and I would be like I
either stood out so much or they think I
look like man or something also I talk
nothing like it oh did you watch Jewish
it was tough fixed up to him yeah he was
thought TV top ten but even he was them
right now no I think he was number six
or something he was like follow yeah but
you go together immediately right after
or what happened how do they go about
well Jimmy you know Jimmy is like a
headline he's one of those you don't say
I got to work right away yeah but he's
one of those people where he's always
been on a road he kills the road even if
you don't
he's maybe not a recognizable face for
you on TV you know
and he he asked me to feature for him
and I before he asked me to feature him
I had never done 25 minutes ever I want
to show not on purpose you know and then
he just see it was like the money's not
that great but you'll think that we
together would be able to sell out all
of these clubs which we did and I was
able to like this that's it quick huh
yeah more like build my material that's
good it's it's it's hard as a woman to
get asked to go feature on the road I
went up yeah when I first started I
asked a few people if I could feature
for them and I was either ignored or
told no and I didn't understand it
because a lot of times people's features
are not good you know and I'll do I just
didn't get it
I was like why do you have this person
featuring oh you and I just thought I
thought that it was because other people
weren't funny and they didn't want to
have to follow somebody that was like
not not just that's probably part of me
but also hungry you know it's just
different type of energy when you get on
stage in you and you're hungry for it
but then once I saw the headlining like
a year and a half ago by myself and I
realized it's really lonely and
sometimes you want your friend there and
your friend may not be that great but
your friend but you spend more time if
you if you're on the road for a weekend
you split you spend more time off stage
and on stage you know and your friends I
think she just broke down every reason
why somebody is a certain person to be
there but I think she just broke down
every reason why that's true they'll
just take the PERT the local person in
town at the club I'm like that I'm like
that you don't you know like you want to
see who they are before you or what kind
of
being a big comedian he was what do you
do all my settled that corner of the
green room and show me his back to hoe
tiny with all his jokes they speak to me
they're given up on stage and I was it
cornered the green room with his head
down the whole time he was a headliner
he was a feature he he was a feature he
was telling about the feature turned
super was calling yeah oh I'm sorry the
headliner turned its back
Oh who's the super famous got me okay
well however whatever this could be
showed up George Lopez and they told all
the comedian's the losers she was
working out stuff in a club I was
already outside okay by the way I wasn't
in the green room waiting for nobody I
knew my place in time there's a
headliner don't go hanging out he was
parking the car solo people showed up
was badass Mercedes and they had the
license plate said punch line and there
Cardos talking to him like small-time
use of the quarter bro yeah let me know
if you need somebody to start the party
if you get rid of that white guy open up
with you know I could go to and
basically that the Willie Barcena shows
up a bro stop sucking his dick already
here he shouldn't go up on stage bro
your other kissing is the a stable
you've seen lame jokes ain't gonna take
your ass dog [ __ ] you dick
anyways so feeling the hot ass car and I
just say what's it what's up he goes
inside all the losers are inside by the
way way too for him to go up a stage you
see with no pads learn new ideas do new
premises oh he's talking about his
grandma I have a grandma
and - they were all gonna get kicked out
you know so he goes in there he sees
everybody throughout with a red faces
and [ __ ] all new comedians are like open
my curse and the manager kicks all of
who's out there are 20 of 10 over
out there over there standing with me by
the car well they should have made it a
beginning and what happened bro [ __ ]
jaw drop is a decade against a solid
unaware bro out of a comical overheated
pedo ticket to get into a comic love
that you need you know you're going up
right no all right then I'm gonna put
your drink in there little burst a hey
man what's up Joe no didn't just saw
immediately those guys they're all in my
space my space
it'll get it right
they don't get it people don't get it
sometimes right
you don't happen to your hair lightening
you got a TED open mic or shove it up to
your ear over a little community gonna
get you oh why are you really at that
level yet but I appreciate you thinking
that that's my life they hit me on
social media down all right
they doing
gonna show up but also I think that I
have a sort of intimidating sort of I
don't know demeanor if you don't know me
at all and so I think it protects me in
a sense that's I feel that some more I
bet nobody becomes in this some more
with [ __ ] husband well he's there
all too but I think reversed herself
like I would be like why are you wasting
my time with this you know like I just
don't think pinky ring has a pinky ring
at the throat diamond ring actually
television he wasn't only working man
you were [ __ ] if she's hosting to new
jokes every time she goes up to him
between she have it or her I thought it
was I thought she had like who's going
up next right but surely Heather in her
head and she goes up on stage before the
show starts and wise like we're gonna
step on ok this [ __ ] this floor is
creaky I don't wanna fall right here so
I'm standing over here all that [ __ ] all
that professional sure that I never do
yeah alright Jayla bar spinning on the
back before doing beatboxing batteries
go off jail am I so good oh my god I
love
[Music]
yeah I'd like oh I whenever I get to see
him live I'm like I was such a pleasure
Lake Tahoe right
Vegas and Laughlin Laughlin any buds of
older lady to party with us
that party was hanging out they were
like kind of they weren't his blood
family but they had always treated him
like family these church ladies you know
we do these nice church ladies one of us
is called the blood with us yeah I'm
surprised we're talking about doing it
she's talking about doing it
oh [ __ ] inhaling whiskey it wasn't a
suntan lotion it was a kid flask but it
was like it looked like a blue suntan
lotion like a gee I can't wait to be
that sort of older woman just have a
flask in my purse she didn't have a flat
on her back before yes I am headlining
the funny bone in Richmond Virginia
Valentine's Day weekend February 14th
which is a Thursday night through Sunday
February 17th it's um
six shows in total so February 1437
things I'm headlining funny bone in
Richmond Virginia so come out and you
guys can follow me on all social media
platforms at st. F Johnson zai Na beat
Johnson my website is a nap Johnson calm
as well fool
what's that bull okay thank you guys for
having me this I would love yeah yeah
fight wheeler said yeah Oh bunny could
it off huh
whatnot tape the yeah just take the well
I would love that I would love to come
back I would love to be a part of the
live show thanks thanks for having me
host yeah I'm gonna wear a tracksuit
next time just give me a warning my god
super bro
you don't say let's take off you know
she's on the way back to Philly
magic tricks give me a couple steps
spider do an audition with and she was
in the audition with other black girls
and I was the only Latino there the only
man there first of all wait for I have
no idea and then they were all like like
supermodel like her like a model type
skinny and I'll see you going man I
think I'm being a I'm auditioning for
like a cold the drug coach supposed to
be like a cheerleader structure or I'm
the wacky janitor where creepy janitor
and we get there they made us do a
letter like improv games at the audition
yeah Chris Spencer he was there yeah
okay Chris ready
okay people coming up shows coming up
Birmingham Alabama
February 15th through the 17th at the
stardome it's a comedy club anybody that
wants ticket for that hit us up work you
up with a pair yes I can do that any day
of the week and we can do that in
Raleigh - also Raleigh North Carolina
favorite 20 seconds were 24th at the
brand-new improv and the way you hit us
up is fans if ans at Felipe's worldcom
and ask for tickets but that's only in a
few kinds a few cities so Raleigh also
to Miami Florida Miami will have some
tickets March 8th
in ten at the brand-new improv I'm gonna
be there all hyped up I'm working out
man I'm drinking a lot of water do a
little walking to show your abs in Miami
no well I'm gonna be like that man I saw
right right in there that uh bicycle man
was up with a speedo he was walking with
a dog huh yeah you took a picture of
that guy was there Coconut Grove bad dog
bad there so late
also you know the coffee kind of almost
like a little bit more than Mexican
people are crazy dude
do you like do you like Tampa better
than Miami for the Cuban town the Cuban
areas or dude which one do you like
better
well Ybor City oh just looking for porn
stars no but when we go to Calle Ocho
like before on our way to La Caleta we
see a lot of smaller shops let's hope
there's no coffee and they solve it I
don't you write little way little shops
but we don't go to the wheel but I was
Miami has more options bad tap only has
one play like whole road and that's it
yeah food-wise who wisest Miami man okay
but for the historical town Ybor City
yeah or City keep going sorry so yeah
Miami but we know chicks in that okay
it's alright st. Petersburg remember
that one time we did that like ten mile
walk talk about that remember and we met
that old man those complaining about
Obama
cuz his his viagra's went up like it was
like dude you still pipe you're like 80
years old though the best others they
beat you yeah on the side of the road
set Angelo Tex
is March 15th at San Angelo Performing
Arts Center
Santangelo worse off like New Orleans
Wichita Kansas March 16 at the Orpheum
Theatre Wichita see you there
I didn't this shows in a sellout so get
your tickets Wichita a lot of people are
Grand Junction Colorado at they were
performing in a train March 23rd at the
Avalon theater get your tickets because
people are showing up from all the way
from Puebla and places Puebla Mexico or
Pueblo Colorado Colorado
Dallas Texas March 29th to 31st
Arlington improv are you ready
kid off the field the Patriots won oh my
god you don't even know how this means
we go play Kosovo it feels just like
last year right and the year before that
right you know it's another really emily
has a question coming up in April but we
don't know when the tickets are going on
sale you can call The Improv and ask
their box office hey when are you
putting the Felipe tickets on sale and
it'll kind of if enough people call
it'll get them to put them on their
checkout Felipe's worldcom slash tour
for all upcoming shows and ticket
information lot of new markets I waited
like my whole life bro for what my whole
life to wear a suit like this your third
one oh but everything this is the
[ __ ] six bit of daughter man Lee
Majors like I've had fake ones bro I
have Pro way stripes they were blue
have done I never have red tennis shoes
and then wanted to get red ones or to
imagine everything bro acting at the
Sigma dollar man bro I never read some
guy Lee Majors a guy had the blue water
somebody said it was a sigma dollar bet
sigma is not a red dog that's a stereo
dollar man
what who showed up he was out he wasn't
like he wasn't 100% working and he got
killed it was all I got was a mustache
he was about 6 min of an episode just
one episode yes remember I thought I saw
all the Six Million Dollar Man you
didn't see that is that what I used to
worry used to were like a like a
Schneider jumpsuit he had several okay
but his main one it just had the logo
over the place right right because that
full right there at Eagle Rock lubos
three majors when I used to wear that
little jumpsuit man you know there was
some do told Toby Higgs about the
[ __ ] dope dealer podcast your babo he
listened to the dope dealer podcast our
ball football are my Buick oh I work
this [ __ ] blood is it an office broad
a cubicle but that for fun of you but go
right there type it on his bum peel all
his C's are broken that's what was
saying everything on the beat I know
when he could sit when Tommy gets drunk
he drop it's like a little black man
must be worse yeah but they had a bond
tract on me
how far do you take it is it every word
in your side every word or occasionally
like no patiently no sees every ovation
the basta tution yo y'all here I could
all brazii I'm over here but Medicaid
I'm hearing ball Erato that was going to
Raleigh doors below right like what he
saying we're going I'll shut I'll see
you guys in Denver baller dude that one
dude that was I'll see your role in
Northborough lider
thank man I'm a bat me son how a brother
was in a pro in a bribe lab you got
bought by the cops
I'm dude that one night remember for we
had us all laughing was all like I sort
of God do this for I was like I can't
believe it your bum pewter can you get
bump you tur what have you lost
it's a batch phrase oh we stuff in a
storm
I had this girl that he met flying
driving in from another town at three
hours and she was going through a storm
too but she already made it to the lobby
and he was all buzzing her back like oh
man she already little whenever she's
already there right and then oh he was
complaining about some other stuff and
then I didn't hit boys the Turner kicked
out the lobby I went over there and I
bought her a bar owner I need to talk to
the pilot heard with him in the
background he was talking to me I heard
Toby Boehner is like we was trying to
ask me like what should we do and I'll
tell him I rented a car just in case you
guys have to drive and I hear Toby in
the back talking to the air the gate
agent if you was me what would you do
what would what decision would you make
this is a
because look we gotta get to Houston by
six o'clock here's like that's really up
to you sir you know I can't tell you
what to do it's we're waiting on whether
it's like it what's unpredictable I got
a girl who got a babysitter they waited
for me it's Bali Italian here daddy
don't know why he was worried so much it
was cause he had a date whatever but
they were at the bar at the time they're
good yeah I don't care she's almost like
lit a cigarette right there a little
eggnog what Mean Gene Okerlund oh do you
wear for interviewing the Hulk Hogan and
Randy Savage with a side talking [ __ ]
bro hold on it's just like this the
whole time he was out of burnt row
ain't no that's a bat that ain't no cat
he said uber Harlee I seen the movies by
the white 5 Isis very formidable you
what a Google [ __ ] I was like it was a
trippy you kind of like a water kind of
thought about it a little bit that one's
full ready to go but dude homeboy like
but that's what dude I didn't even know
like he was I thought he came from like
a political family did he see that one
hair when Donald Rumsfeld at that other
eight conclusions i am i work for DNC so
I'm gonna take the Democrat guy oh well
what is he yeah he's a Republican that's
what I think about like how people in
America or how they pick political side
just because they like someone's
personality into an Rumsfeld was like
you think he's all serious he was just
like like cracking jokes about him but
why war wouldn't put him straight
well his wife started speaking but
everywhere they war
oh yeah I think yeah it was a trip I
thought it was really good it wasn't
what I expected but he's a good actor
right come on good Larry right you
nailed it nasty dude it was a Friday of
every week
that's comedy well I was surprised at
first but I mean I get it yeah if you
really look at it it's funny but it is
really like disturbing at the same time
because all these facts are crazy and I
hope we always knew this that's crazy
what they say well when I wrote I said
people is huh well they thought it's our
ISM do you think do you think someone's
gonna go to jail here's the first I mean
he I think training was the first to
really start the whole tying marketing
and to basically having marketing teams
and focus groups and stuff like that
genius also using law and then using
lawyers and I mean to do the focus group
on calling the estate tax to death tax
you know and Trump said it last night he
said the estate tax and he cut himself
off and he said death tax because death
tax hugs at the middle America's
heartstrings I don't want my family have
to pay none of you will have to pay
because you don't make enough you don't
have enough we saw Vice I haven't seen
the one with the Melissa McCarthy yet
but I seen the wife how about the movie
when I was frustrated with the wife yeah
why she I was because I was I was
frustrated because she did because when
she broke down for him and said look
[ __ ] like you're where you are
because of my words but he didn't even
know his characters nothing wife the
wife yeah so she's down he fell asleep
but wife she breaks me she breaks down
you know and and when they're having
their fight before you know whatever
happens to him but she breaks down and
she's like you know frustrated that he's
never recognized her for that and pushed
her to the side and all she doesn't
right you know and telling everybody
that but then when it came down to it
and the biographer wanted
to say something about that after he/she
says you know [ __ ] with his legs don't
[ __ ] with his legacy I'll take you to
court like she she'd never she still
holds the line for her dead husband
Christian Slater was good and how about
the in that think about [ __ ] like that
is it you're dealing with the kids and
the kid wants to be a writer too it was
very bad spot for in just like Holly
through the little Nobel Prize out the
window
it was crazy there
I seen the wife I seen I didn't see the
[Music]
wife is good right oh yeah it was but my
thing about vice was the second time it
came around with george w bush cuz he
already got the they got the experience
with nixon and then later with general
Ford but also how they put up the people
that they knew how weak they were how to
work that's why experience matters but
they're they're like funny how long well
everybody who mixes organization was
done right nobody anybody behind him was
done and those who were already out
rumsfeld and cheney
so when they came in after he lived at
the new fresh blood that there was some
pretty much clean yeah and he got behind
on board right right what they got we
had four door no no they were already
there but ford was his vp right yeah so
he came into power and then those fools
convinced them to get rid of kissinger
that's out of here and got those fools i
mean that takes like very like
calculated that active people to do that
[ __ ] and me you might not under like
cheney but i understand what he's doing
in like how yeah i mean if you don't
like him you have to realize how
brilliantly yeah conniving and
manipulative he was just like he was
like he accomplished everything he
wanted to and the legacy of it it's
continuing frustrate us every day did
you see a house cooter
he was working for him and he's the one
that leaked it and over that I see a
connection was my biggest surprise I
didn't know that that he knew them was
for like Reagan appointed with I had no
idea before the whole Bush thing ends up
in the Supreme Court's hands bush-gore
thing I had no idea that Scalia had a
connection and I bet a lot of people
didn't know how powerful these think
tanks are who pours money into him he's
still alive right - yeah yeah after all
this what doing that heart that he got
though like that's he was a distant
cousin that little because the guy that
you guys called the fat Matt Damon yeah
he was a distant cousin like when he was
in war before he went in a war cuz he
actually win a war but I tripped out
they never released I don't think it was
a cousin I thought he was just some he
got the heart cuz that guy died okay cuz
he's go back I'll try to go back yeah
yeah yeah is it I'm a distant third
cousin Oh cuz I thought he said we're
connected and I'll tell you how and I
thought they were only connected because
his heart was in dip that's how I didn't
get that there because you know the
other things he was like how are ya he
parlayed a job for his daughter in the
Pentagon and then later in Congress and
how still there how they slipped how
they flipped the thing of the daughter
you know she's obviously a lesbian or
whatnot and then they like she held her
stance on TV and became she wasn't
holding her stance she was yeah she was
lying she wasn't choosing the other side
just so she can get up there how do you
about the trouble would you guys think
about the State of the Union guys
watching good comedy show huh
I've always cringe at every State of the
Union doesn't matter who I was about it
cost her every single thing I wants to
father would it cost somebody in his
family was killed by the illegal alien
you know I hate when they don't like but
they're like like the root the real
people are asking how many illegal
aliens shut up a school you bring any of
the shooters he did bring over it bring
up that Pittsburgh shoot him though and
the survivor he was a police officer
right or was an EMT the old man survived
but one thing that was crazy was like I
heard a comic he looked very
presidential
yeah I just I hate always hate the State
of the Union I don't know if it I don't
know it's I feel like a pep rally yeah
that's what everybody was saying like
there wasn't much substance it was kind
of like a campaign stop that's what it
felt like and he's gonna fight AIDS and
like it's gonna be done in two in
limited ten years like you fight a low
sword it's it's already pretty I mean
it's not over of course but you know we
have a lot of you know almost almost a
cure basically for all purposes like it
we're close already 20 2005 hand was
hurting it annoys me the standing up and
clapping it's just like even people who
don't like him like you stand up and do
it
Pelosi cuz wasn't like the state is
Union wasn't that originally just a
letter to Congress yeah I was always in
writing and Woodrow Wilson and people
act like it's like yeah it's
I don't know funny but it's me was
ceremony oh no I don't any but Riverside
we're working on any room in downtown
Riverside so I'll let you guys know asap
and check out the mmm podcast so which
is I definitely special we're still
working it out but we're gonna have one
film this year we don't know where we
don't know when English one and then
another one in Spanish well sorry
material different language right now
people if you're watching me right now
or listening to me on other wonderful
pod can let me know if you were paid to
watch me do 100% Spanish special one
hour and then watch the same special
more than a percent in English the next
day
so we're thinking about I'm doing up
special in Spanish to shows in Spanish
and then one hour every night and the
second show would be and the second a
second day will be an English teacher
shows so it'll be one show it could take
your family with you know to get morrow
ticket uncle's take anybody who speak
Spanish who uh who you want to do who
otherwise might stand special being
taped and the next day's gonna be for
the for the big dogs all in English
exclusively all in English and then I
mean all in English and the day of the
special we're gonna probably have it all
in Spanish like completely in Spanish
where everybody see me speaking Spanish
to the show the director everybody every
other direction of being Spanish so what
you gonna hopefully at least like a
direct that one you could you could
direct it with whoever gets the red
negative I need one I need a live show
director I don't think I'm ready for
that to coordinate cameras and stuff I
don't think I'm ready a bird soon
I predicted a couple Scheider closing
come over the table in Spanish I'm down
for whatever you know me no I say I say
Black Widow a Spanish Buda Buda Buda I
don't know
yes bozos time where - what's up fool
we're ready for no special I brought
ready for another special I went to the
comedy store last week bro how was it
for I started touching Leggero
I saw Anthony Jeselnik some girl named
Shawn they Greenstein her Diaz will be
coordinating he left right after I said
huh took off what's up fool we might
have our angel sparse a cameo on a
special somebody just said so there
about is he gonna be coming in the next
camera I'm sorry what's up fools hurries
to the care about people I know we sent
him a couple hoodies I bet he did so
will you tired out for this weekend a
little bit yeah you work cuz you went to
bed at like 10 the first night and I
think he went to bed it
you were asking at 9:45 if I hate you if
he went to bed why slip out from 9:45
all the way to 8 in the morning dog like
clean out no edibles that your body
needs that rest man I pass out nasty on
Monday pushy for walks every night how
she doing good what's up fool
oh we didn't get to take a picture with
saying that the pictures were talking
okay
did you take a picture with her no she
was really really really cool in sheep
in the game right Wow bad 13 kids bro
she should be a funny joke if she were
doing that I like to you know rubric
that you know right so yeah I'd cover
about 13 family yes almost hooray yeah
yeah you stand for that joke you your
family 7 7 kids yeah your mom's family
how because hers you would have been 9
though your mom had to had twins that
were stillborn yes - oh boy so that was
in between Fernando and between the
Ranger me until you go after so mom I
got pregnant right after losing both
kids little fuck-around I would have
people call I guess it does good boy
then she's probably like doing housework
and like I better get out of here
I want the bullying dad wrote horrible
my mom made me laugh with a kind of flat
ball
read a book
okay ain't big enough yeah went over
there oh they drug you when they put it
in not now uh-huh oh yeah all the way
decide yeah for what because when you're
sleeping for a long time or in surgery
and then recovering or maybe on some
drugs you don't have control of your
bladder so you pee all over yourself so
they do this and sometimes they want to
monitor how much urine you're producing
so they could see I had a catheter with
my last surgery I didn't even know it
and then she was like oh we're gonna
take the catheter out when I was asleep
I remember it but I told you that one
time when I was a nurse's assistant in
the home for older people that one guy
with brain cancer he they put a cat he
had a permanent catheter in that we had
to change like every couple days just
plug into it yeah but he got so
frustrated with it he was in pain
constantly cuz he had brain cancer he
was dying he yanked it out one time with
the bulb inflated it just went right
through the urethra with the bulb fully
inflated there was blood everywhere and
I had to go get the nurse and it was a
male nurse on stuff that night he almost
fainted when he saw it he knew what had
happened and he was imagining the pain
of it my grandfather morphine
this guy every second of every day he
just said god help me Jesus help me god
help me Jesus help me it was so sad sad
he wanted to die nobody's picking up
today awful
I did a krinkle will do it over there
right now those falling clothes
sure you got a card game going on right
now something he's over there Foley
blows was so full podcast thank you very
much everybody listen to the podcast
think everybody was showing up to
Coachella we're awesome time and we show
this what's up Jay Robbie's going over
there to pick up food tell them they
they tell me we don't have it we don't
fight for our booty well that's what I
was gonna say but if I do dead is
basically dead right here like he's hung
up like that dude come on man I was all
bummed out about that [ __ ] when the she
doesn't go as planned
and they're like there's no food dogs so
they receive for the money back it's
like dude how could he give it to
somebody who's like yeah it's [ __ ]
dog welcome to the Korowai nested you
get that fluoride will happen bro off
the weapon a casino bar the far so what
do you say commandeered that fool driver
has a truck broke over a freeware then I
said listen man I just over here you
know man you know they have 40 right so
chill a [ __ ] look at hazard dude
did he kill me when you said yep this
flew over here didn't you you ain't
gonna fall be asleep behind the wheel on
dawg I know it looks like he's sleepy
all the time I was afraid I was like you
let him drive videos i dude what's wrong
with that will get him survived it's
like this hello there's a ghost carried
him by the hair
put the [ __ ] Charlie rough game tube
here looking like Tobey from the office
see that one would Toby like try to kiss
is it you try to kiss Pam and then he
ran no he touches her lay yeah
and they realize everybody look
everybody sees him and everybody's
shocked and he realizes what he's done
and then he comes back yeah it comes
back after like a year in Costa Rica
Toby ready go hell yeah males foreign
man over there I said good though the
night after the day after the shore
Saturday I do it all on Sunday nasty
fool Oh star B star be sure to have Dan
Frank company Godzilla cuckoo the camera
blu-ray [ __ ] Dhamma six nine Franciscan
they have shoes every Breck a multi germ
the John Sanchez Danny I just mention
that for so I put the Comedy Store for
Robert longer and later about the last
refer I can read it title read long
messages that Omar Gonzalez first his
brother his shoes he's an Albuquerque
for steps vlogs I saw a food I give you
that blood brought the Comedy Store
Kenny Frank daddy Frank bro that forward
to the car Chicago the next day then a
spot at the Laugh Factory or they be
somewhere I say you're not gonna make it
therefore they make it bro [ __ ] hold
of it on tartikoff day freedom were some
fool young danger yeah Oh mothers are
less well Car Show podcast was so fool